[Applaudissements]
quand votre frère c'est simple on arrête
des gens dans la rue on pose une
question on s'habille comme eux et la
voilà avatar quoi regarder c'est énorme
ce que fait cadeau qu'est ce que vous
pensez des transports en commun
parisiens alors je pense que c'est un
peu cher mais comme ça marche bien ça
marche super donc moi je suis plutôt
contente je me plains pas de petit truc
comme ah ouais ça pue
il ya des clodos et tout ça ça ça me
dérange pas c'est un peu partout pareil
donc quand ça fonctionne bien il n'y a
pas de retard c'est bien ça fait drôle
ou de temps en temps et votre charme en
pense quoi
ma soeur ma soeur elle n'est pas
parisien n'avait pas là alors on est
fichu on n'est pas fichu
les soeurs olsen elles ont bien grandi
je sais très bien pour les gens qui
n'ont pas de véhicule ou d'obligations
en matière d'horaires
mais moi mon choix portent sur la moto
car je travaille sous en banlieue dans
paris ou dans différents arrondissements
et ça me permet d'être à l'heure mais
rendez vous votre frère ils en pensent
quoi confrères et libyens
bon je te laisse quand on prend le métro
ou trois fois par jour même quelques
pannes abondamment alpha devient pauchet
et votre soeur elle en pense quoi
mais celle comment tout va bien vous
êtes ma selle s'émouvoir ma seule en
italie tutti quanti tiramisu pas
d'accord tu as très compliqué souvent
attendre une heure c'est pas pratique
après je pense qu'en tant que parisien
n'est souvent habitué à faire au moins
20 minutes à 40 minutes de métro et
votre challans penses quoi
nasser qu'est ce qu'elle en pense j'ai
pas de sa race sa petite soeur j que
encore 13 ans et demi dont 14 la
surveille en fait ouais je sorte avec
tivo il m'a brisé le coeur
smile et des larmes ces petits bouts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]